so we should have you ever had a ghostly
or supernatural experience no to end
will I find it I do and I like hearing
other people's stories and I really
believe other people's stories and but I
just haven't had my own how do you think
how do you think you would react to to a
ghost I hope with a sort of benevolent
curiosity like not fear but more like
you want to be a medium base yeah
exactly yeah I want to like be curious
about and not reactive mm-hm what scares
you the most what scares me the most
cockroach mm-hm
apostrophe s's legs and moving patterns
any books and no just that oh okay where
they can go and and just sort of how
they have like the great glass elevator
dynamic where you're like you could go
any direction I don't like it how do you
feel about flying cockroaches oh I
thought you meant going into huh oh yeah
I really enjoyed the Universal Studios
spook fest thing this year I got spooked
a number of times there was a clown one
which is not normally my thing but it
was really great and a lot of oh and
then there was sort of like a Pan's
Labyrinth type of large beings with like
arms that swoop that a also liked so you
like people popping out at you yeah like
people getting close enough to touch but
never brushing did you look back at the
turn of the screw when you were taking
this part any sort of the previous
iterations or not that I mean I'd seen
the innocence ages ago and then the
novella I was I didn't want to rewatch
the most obviously I was constantly I
mean our movie is an adaptation it's not
like you know
verse by verse yeah thankful adaptation
of the novella but I wanted to make sure
that this sort of essence in the tone
and the spirit of why that's a special
piece of writing kept coming back so I
tried to use that to ground some of the
stuff when you get a script like say the
turn turning what tends to be the first
thing you do sort of prepare for the
character um I don't know I go through
and try and feel like what I intuitively
don't believe like whatever blocks me at
first and then try and understand those
parts and then and then move through it
I don't know in this movie the sort of
the aesthetics were really helpful to me
like Kate's progression and building
that with with our lovely hair and
makeup and costume ladies was such a fun
thing to be like okay and like what is
this phase of her life look like because
it was like this Pavlovian thing where
you'd get into that zone and immediately
you'd be like okay obviously what
blocked you when you first read the
script but where the what were the
pieces two years ago do you find it hard
to imagine someone has seen the movie it
has did the script change at all when
you came aboard do you remember that
yeah I did it was it was it was moving a
lot really yeah it was it was a thing
that we were really trying to find the
right version of this thing that felt
still scary but faithful to the novella
because the novellas scary in a way
that's not like super marketable I think
or like it's not it's not I don't know
it's like it's creepy but it's not going
to you know you might not scream that
much and so how do you create a movie
that still as a horror movie and still
satisfies this sort of like communal
expression of grief and fear but that is
in
dicing a thing that is so wonderful to
begin with what was it like filming it
in this sort of gigantic house it was
cool this it was cool you felt like
Richie Rich or something he's great just
like wander around this state and think
that all this is mine so you would move
in